So just to, um, just to review,
here's where we left off the discussion
from last lecture and for about half of
this lecture is going
to be social psychology.
And so we started off by talking about
certain fundamental biases and how we see
ourselves. We then turn to talk about
a bias and how we see other people,
the fundamental attribution error.
And now we're talking a little bit
about some aspects of how we see other
people.
So we quickly talked about
certain aspects of um,
of why we like other
people including proximity,
similarity and attractiveness.
And where we left off was the
discussion of the Matthew effect,
which is basically that good
things tend to compound. If you're,
if you're rich, you'll get a
better education. If you're
smart, people will like,
you will like you more if
you're attractive and so on.
Nobody bring up their
papers at this point. They,
we'll collect them at the end of class.
Um,
what I want to talk to.
Okay. Except for you ending it now. Um,
I'm going to ask the teaching fellows
to stop anybody from approaching that,
that area. I want to begin by talking
about him, about impression formation,
how we form impressions of others and
tell you a couple of interesting things
about impression formation.
I'm the first one is first
impressions matter a lot.
They matter a lot. Um,
for different reasons.
They might matter a lot because humans
have in general a confirmation bias such
that once you believe something,
other information is then encoded along
the lights to support what you believe.
So the classic study here was done by
Kelly where a guest speaker comes in and
some of the students received a bio
describing the speaker as very warm.
The other as do not bring your paper up
if you're coming in late just at the end
of the class. Yeah. Um,
others got a bio saying, thanks
Eric. This speaker was rather cold.
And then it turned out later on when
they're asked for their impressions of the
speaker,
people are very much biased
by what they first assumed.
If I'm described to you as a VI Vaishyas
and creative person and you see me and
I'm all kind of bouncing around and you
could then confirm this as look how by
Vaishyas and creative he is. If I'm
described as somebody who drinks too much,
you might think he's an alcoholic. It
was you had to describe to somebody who,
who's who's insecure and nervous.
You could interpret my
activity as nervous twitches.
Your first impression sets a framework
from which you interpret everything else.
This was the theme of an excellent
movie called being there starring Peter
Sellers and a running joke of the movie
being there was the domain character,
the character Chauncey Gardner,
somehow through accident had the
reputation for being a genius.
But while in reality he was
actually mildly retarded,
but he would go around and people would
ask him his opinions on politics and he
would say things like,
oh,
well I like being in the garden and
because of his reputation as a genius,
people said, wow, that's very profound.
I wonder what he means and or people
talk to me, just stare at them and say,
and people would say would be intimidated
by his bold and impetuous stare when
match. You just totally
didn't know anything. Um,
so first impressions can
shape subsequent impressions,
not just when dealing with people.
A little while ago there was a sniper,
actually a pair of snipers
killing people in Washington.
And the one thing everybody knew about
it was there was a white van involved.
Turned out there was no white van at all.
But in the first incident,
somebody saw a white van,
this was reported in all the newspapers.
Then every other incident people
started seeing the white vans.
They started looking for them, they
started to attending, attending them.
So first impressions matter hugely when
dealing with people because it sets the
stage for how we
interpret everything else.
A second finding building on the first
is that we form impressions very fast,
very quickly.
And this is a literature
known as thin slices.
The idea is you don't have to see much
of a person to get an impression of what
they are. The first studies done on
this were actually done on teachers,
on university professors.
So University professors have teaching
evaluations and you could use this as a
rough and ready approximation
of what students think of them.
So what you do then as the question that
these people were interested in, um,
Rosenthal and I'm body, uh,
two social psychologists were,
how long do you have to
look at a professor to guess
how popular a teacher he
is?
So they show these clips for a full class.
Do you have to see him for a full class?
Do you have to see him for two classes?
Do you have to see him for a half hour?
How long do you have to be
around a person to see him,
to estimate how good a
lecture that person is?
And the answer is five seconds.
So after clips of five seconds,
people are pretty good at predicting
what sort of evaluations that person will
have. Um, remember the Big Five,
how we evaluate people on a big five.
Well you have a roommate
and your roommate,
you could evaluate it under big five.
You've had a lot of experience with him
or her, how much time do you need to,
to evaluate somebody on the
five dimensions of personality?
Answer is again,
not much time at all.
After very brief exposures to people,
people are very accurate at
identifying them on the big five.
One of the more surprising findings
is concerned sexual orientation or
Gaydar is not a scientific term.
Um,
but at the same psychologist
we're interested in studying
how quickly you can,
if at all, how long does it take to
figure out somebody's sexual orientation.
Now what they did was they
were clever psychologists,
so they set it up in a study where the
people did not know sexual orientation
was that issue. So for instance, they may
be people like you who filled in a form.
One question along a very long form was
your sexual orientation and then you're
sitting down being interviewed by somebody
and your interview is being filmed.
And then other people are shown who
don't know. You are shown the film.
And the finding is
that people based on thin slices
are quite good at detecting
sexual orientation. Um,
everybody's good at it. Gay People
are better at it than straight people.
And again, you don't need much
time. You just need about a second.
You see somebody for about a second.
You can make a guess. You're,
you're far from always right. In fact,
you're just a bit better than chance,
but you are better than chance at
telling sexual orientation. Um,
so these two facts taken together then
slices and the power of first impressions
means that just by a brief
exposure to somebody,
it shaped so much of how you're going
to think about them in the future.
Now we can look at this
from the other direction.
We're talking about the
perceptions of other people,
how we perceive other people.
But social psychologists
are also interested in the
question of what happens to
other people as a result of
being perceived in a certain way.
So one question is,
what would cause me to,
to perceive somebody as intelligent
or stupid gay or straight anxious or,
or, or levelheaded? A second question is,
what are the effects of
being judged that way?
And psychologists have coined a term,
um,
talk about self fulfilling prophecies.
And the claim here more specifically is
what's known as the Pygmalion effect and
the Pygmalion effect is,
um,
if I believe you have a
certain characteristic,
this might cause you to behave as
if you have that characteristic.
Um,
the name comes from the
play by George Bernard Shaw,
Pygmalion.
Um,
and the quote here is the
difference between a lady
and a flower girl is not how
she behaves, but how she's treated.
I shall always be a flower girl,
but Professor Higgins,
cause he always treats me as a flower
girl and always will made into a better
known movie. Uh, my fair
lady. But I think that this,
the same theme is better
exemplified in a far better movie.
La femme.
Nikita where we're a cold blooded killer
is treated with respect and affection.
And then she becomes,
um,
a much more warm and accessible person
and then she kills a lot of people.
But that, but, but, but still,
it illustrates the point.
And this point has tons
of empirical validity.
The classic experiment was by
Rosenthal and Jackson where, um,
they told teachers that some of their
kids were really smart and other kids
were, were less, we're not really smart.
They weren't expected to show a
huge jump or spurt in it. Our ICU.
Um, and this was of course trickery.
The children were chosen at random,
but the children who were
described as showing as,
as expected to show a jump in Iq in
fact did show a jump in their Iq scores.
And this isn't magic.
It's basically if I am totally,
you're a genius and your genius is about
to be in full flower throughout this
class and it's a small class as these
classes where I'll focus more on you,
I'll give you more of my attention.
If I'm told not so much for you,
you'll put your, y'all, you
all suffer relative to him.
And so the Pygmalion effect shows how
our expectations can really matter.
Um,
this brings us to the final,
the issue of expectations and um,
how we judge people is a story
that can be told but individuals.
But it's also a story that
can be told about groups.
And this is where I want to end this
section on social psychology by talking
about groups.
A lot of social psychology is concerned
with the question of how we think about
human groups.
And we've already discussed this in the
lecture on morality when we talked about
the human dynamic pushing us to think in
terms of us versus them as shown in the
robber's cave study and also shown in
the minimal group research by Taj fell.
Showing that from a motivational
emotional standpoint, um,
it's not difficult for us to think in
terms of my group versus your group.
And this way of thinking has real
consequences for our emotional life,
our effective life and how we
choose to distribute resources.
What I want to talk about here though
is a different aspect of how we think
about human groups. I want to talk
a little bit about stereotypes.
Now.
Stereotypes in English
often just is a bad word.
To have. A stereotype is, is to be,
is to have something wrong with you.
You might say it's not
good to have stereotypes.
Psychologists tend to use the
term in a broader sense. Um,
we tend to use the term to refer to
information we have about categories and
intuitions we have about the typicality,
our frequency of certain
features of categories.
And it turns out that
collecting information about
categories is essential to
our survival. Um, we, we,
we see novel things all the time and
if we were not capable of learning and
making guests as educated guesses
about these novel things, um,
we would not be able to survive.
So when you see this object over here,
you categorize it as a chair and you
recognize that you could probably sit on
it.
This apple is probably addable.
This dog probably barks and has
a tail and eat meat, eats meat,
and doesn't speak English.
These are all stereotypes about chairs
and about apples and about dogs.
That doesn't mean they are logically true.
This can be a vegetarian dog,
a poison apple and explosive chair,
but they're typically true.
And if you were suddenly stripped of
your ability to make generalizations,
you'd be at a loss. You wouldn't
know what to eat, how to interact.
So some sort of ability to,
to record information and
make generalizations is
absolutely essential to making
it through life was interesting though
is we also categorize types of people.
So we have stereotypes in our heads
about men and women, about children,
adolescents or adults, whites,
blacks, Asians and so on.
Now this is not essentially a bad
thing for a couple of reasons.
First,
some of these stereotypes are positive.
You might have positive
stereotypes about certain groups.
You might believe some groups are
unusually creative or intelligent.
You might have,
um,
you might have a particularly positive
stereotype about your own group,
even if your own group is Yale.
Students are your own group is people
from France or your own group is people
from such and so college you
might have positive stereotypes.
More importantly,
um,
we collect stereotypes about groups
of people through much the same way we
collect stereotypes about categories
like cherries and apples and dogs.
And so they're pretty often accurate
when there are studies,
um,
which asks people who is
more likely to be a lawyer,
someone who's Jewish or someone who's
Hispanic, who's likely to be taller.
Somebody from Japan or
somebody from Sweden,
people can answer these things.
They have their stereotypes at guide
your answers and the answers are not
arbitrary. I ran under,
answered her often correct. Um,
and often possessing stereotypes
listens to make reasonable and correct
generalizations about the world.
That's a sort of good news about
stereotypes, but it was also bad news.
One problem is they're not always accurate
and there's a couple of factors that
could lead them away from accuracy.
One is what we talked about before
regarding first impressions,
which is a confirmation bias.
If you believe that
homosexuals are FM minute,
that gay men are feminine,
um,
then this is going to shape
how you see future game at.
If you see in a feminine gay
man, you'll probably say, ah,
more evidence for my theory.
Um,
if you see a man who's not a feminist,
you might ignore it or saying maybe
he's not really gay after all. Um,
if you believe black men are criminals,
then when you see a black
man who is a criminal, you,
you'll track it down as support,
but you'll pay less attention to evidence
that white men are criminals and some
black men are not criminals. You
won't look at this as a scientist. Um,
objectively scanning data. Rather,
you'll be biased in certain ways.
Um,
you'll be biased to put extra weight on
the cases that support your theory and,
um, and diminish cases that
refute it. Furthermore,
our data is not always reliable.
So,
oh, and this is actually an
example of this at work. Um,
it turns out, uh, in the
world of classical music,
there's a stereotype of women being
simply less proficient than men.
They play smaller than men. They don't
have the same force. And, and, and,
and they have smaller techniques.
They're more temperamental and so on. Um,
if you asked somebody who was a
judge, the judge would say, look,
this is just the way things are.
I'm not being biased at all.
The tests of this then is to how blind
auditions where people do their auditions
behind screen.
So you can't tell whether they're a
man or a woman or for that matter,
white or black or Asian or whatever.
It turns out when you do that,
women get hired far more suggesting that
the stereotype is a incorrect and B has
a real negative and unfair
effect on people getting hired.
A second problem is what I was talking
about immediately before this is some of
our data are misleading.
So we get a lot of the information
about the world from the media.
The media would include
television and movies, but um,
but would also include
plays and books and stories.
And to the extent these for Trey,
um,
an unrealistic or unfair or
biased perception of the world,
we could construct stereotypes that
are faithful to the data we're getting,
but the data is not
representative. Um, and so people,
for instance,
a object to the fact that that when
there's Italian Americans on TV,
they're often members of the
sopranos, a mobster family. Uh,
throughout history,
Jews have been upset at the portrayal
of Shylock in merchant of Venice,
not a very nice guy.
Um,
and often in response, people who
want to foster more positive views,
we'll often try to,
we'll,
we'll often put in representatives from
other groups in unusual ways to make
that point.
Anybody here ever seen a television show?
Battlestar Galactica.
Okay.
Was that
he's the star of Battlestar Galactica.
You don't know cause you're,
you're too young in the
original Battlestar and,
and I, I hate you. And in an original,
in the original Battlestar Galactica,
this was the star.
This was the main character known as
Starbuck who got transformed into a woman
in the more reason.
One,
I sort of example of how portrayals
are shifting in interesting ways.
There's also of course,
um,
moral problems over stereotypes.
So it's fine to judge chairs and
apples and dogs based on a stereotype.
It's even find to judge breeds of dogs.
If I told you that I decided to,
to,
um,
to buy a grey hound instead of a pit
bull because I wanted a dog of a gentle
temperament, nobody would scream
that I'm a dog racist involvement.
And,
but honestly it's a stereotype.
Greyhounds are supposed to be more
passive in gentle then pimples.
I think it's a true stereotype
but as a stereotype nonetheless,
but we have no problems when it comes
to things like breeds of dogs with
stereotypes. We have serious
problems judging people this way.
So for instance, it's a moral principle
at some of us would hold to that.
Even if stereotypes are correct,
it is still immoral to apply
them in day to day life. Um,
the term for this would be profiling.
Now it gets complicated because there
some cases where we do allow stereotypes
to play a role.
When you all go and get driver's licenses
or when you did get driver's licenses,
you have to pay higher,
higher auto insurance premiums than I do.
I think this is perfectly fair because
young people like you get into a lot more
accidents with your
reefer and your alcohol
and so it is now.
Now some of you were saying that's
a stereotype and it is a stereotype,
but this is distinctly robust one
and nobody lives up to protest this.
It's an acceptable stereotype
to make a generalization from.
On the other hand,
what if insurance companies a determined
that people from Asia got into more
accidents than people from Europe?
Would people be equally comfortable
charging people from Asia?
Higher rates of insurance?
Almost certainly not.
So the issues are complicated as to
what sort of generalizations where are
reasonable to make and what what aren't.
There's also a second problem.
Stereotypes have all sorts of effects.
Now some of them are obvious effects.
Um, you know, if people, for instance,
if people pull pull you over while
you're driving because you're black,
um, this could have a huge effect on how
you feel welcome in a society on race
relations and so on.
But some of the affects are more
subtle and more interesting.
And you might not expect this.
And this is some work done
by the psychologist Claude
Steele and his colleagues
at Stanford.
And the issue is called stereotype threat.
Imagine you have a math test and
this is the front of the math test.
Claude Steele made an
interesting discovery here is
how to make black people do
worse on this math test.
It's very simple.
The finding is that if your race or
your group has a negative stereotype
associated with it in
any particular domain,
being reminded of it serves as a
stereotype threat and hence damages your
performance in all sorts of domains.
If the stereotype is your
group doesn't do goodness,
if I remind you that you remember that
group immediately before doing it,
your performance will drop.
Um,
now you know how make women
do worse on math tests too
like that.
And this has a demonstrative effect.
So stereotypes are complicated
and morally fraught things.
Um,
when people study stereotypes,
they often make certain distinctions
between three levels of stereotypes.
Um, and this is nicely
summarized here. There is public,
if I asked you, um, one of the,
one of the people running for the
Democratic nominee for president is black.
Another one is female.
Um,
if I ask people to raise their hands for,
um,
who thinks that because being black,
because being female,
they should be automatically
disqualified for being president.
Few of you would raise your hands.
Those are your public
presentations of stereotypes.
Even if I was to ask
you on a sheet of paper,
you might deny it because you might
be afraid that it's not anonymous.
Then there's private.
Private is what you really think,
but you don't tell people.
Some of you,
some of the population United States are
not going to vote for somebody because
he or she is black, but they won't
tell you, but they know it to be true.
That's common sense.
What's more interesting is below even
that there may be unconscious associations
that work that people don't actually know
about but affects their thoughts about
race, gender, and other social groups.
Okay,
so here's some data about
what people publicly say. Um,
this is the proportion of
people who say they will vote.
They would vote for an African
American president. Um,
what's interesting is when I'm around,
when I was born dancer,
United States was about half.
Now it is as close to a hundred
percent as you can get it.
Here's another one.
This is also public stereotypes of blacks.
Proportion of white respondents
endorsing each trait.
Now it's infant decimal.
These numbers are so are so low,
they could be dismissed as people filling
in the wrong things or making jokes or
just being confused. Um, compared
to compared to, you know,
stunningly superstitious high rankings.
And so there's been a profound
change in public presentations,
public views on race.
But what about implicit views?
This gets more complicated.
Here's a simple study. This is a sort
of study that you might do here at Yale.
Um, where you might do, for instance,
is be sitting in a computer screen and
you'll be an incomplete words to fill out
like Haas,
and you have to fill out this word.
What you don't know is that pictures of
black faces or pictures of white faces
are being flashed on the screen,
but it being flashed on the
screen subliminally so fast,
you don't even know you're seeing them.
Still,
this has an effect when
you see black faces.
Subjects are more likely to fill
this before it's like hostile,
while Weiss, more likely to fill
it out. Words like hospital.
Um,
I will now welcome you to participate
in an experiment on implicit attitudes.
This was developed by Mazarine Banaji
who used to be a Yale and now is in a
inferior university in
Boston. Um, and um, and,
and it's called the implicit attitudes
test is the biggest psychology experiment
ever done in terms of people I don't like.
1 million people have participated in
this, and you could just go online,
implicit.harvard.edu.
Uh,
and then you could do it yourself,
but we'll do it now as a group.
If you did it in the lab
are on your computer screen,
you would do it by pushing buttons.
We'll do it by speaking,
and it's very simple.
You're going to see things over here and
you're are going to be words or they're
going to be pictures.
If it's an African American or a bad word,
a negative word.
I want you to shout out right this side,
right?
If it's a white American or a good word,
I want you to shut out,
left people ready.
Try to do it as fast as possible
without making any mistakes,
okay? Because of the very loud wrong
person, we're going to try it again.
Ready?
Good.
That is congruent.
Congruent according to a
theory that says that people,
both African Americans
and white Americans, um,
have biases to favor white
Americans or African Americans.
How do we know about this? Where
we compare it? That's congruent.
Now it's different
if it's a white American or a bad word,
say right? If it's an African
American or a good word,
say left.
Okay.
Um,
for all I can tell
people did equally well,
but this experiment has been done tens
of thousands of times and you could do it
yourself on a computer screen
and this is one way of doing it.
But I'll alternate and I'll give you
different ones to shift around and
everything.
And it turns out that this version
people are slower at than other version
suggesting that they're suggesting that
there are associations run one way and
not the other. And this work has
been extended for all sorts of ways.
I'm looking at, for example, a gender,
looking at the connection between
women and English and men at math,
looking at age,
uh,
attitudes towards,
people who are obese versus people who
are thin attitudes towards people who are
straight versus people who are gay.
And you could go online and do these
studies and I'll give you some feeling for
the sort of implicit attitudes
that we have within us.
Well, a legitimate question
is who cares? I mean,
if you do the,
if you look at the results for this study,
it turns out that there is an association
as bias to view White Americans as
positive and African
Americans as negative,
but it shows up like half a second
difference. Who Cares? Well,
there's two answers to
this. One answer is, um,
there are times in your life we're
half a second can matter a lot. Um,
so studies with police officers using
reaction time and split second choices on
who to shoot, fine, that your
stereotypical attitudes, um,
play a huge role in who you're likely to
shoot when they're holding an object in
their hand.
That's unclear also more generally.
It could be that these implicit attitudes
play a role in judgment calls in cases
where you have a hard decision to
make. You know, you're not racist.
You have no explicit racist
attitudes. Honestly, you really don't.
But the argument is that these stereotypes
can affect your behavior in all sorts
of subtle ways. Here's one example. Um,
what they do is they do an experiment
where somebody is in trouble.
You hear a scream from outside,
either from a black person or a
white person in one condition,
you're the only person
around in another condition.
There's other people around you.
Now we know from work in the
bystander effect that in general,
which one are we more likely to help him
when were the only person or multiple
only. Exactly. And in fact,
when it's the only person just about
everybody helps regardless of the color of
the person in trouble.
But when you're with other people,
there's a big difference.
Now again, this isn't,
these studies are not done
with members of the KKK.
They're done with winter in standard
university undergraduates like you. Um,
and these are,
and if you were in this group,
you wouldn't say, oh, I didn't want
to help because the person's black.
Rather what you would say is,
well,
I didn't think it was worth helping or
other people around someone else would
help.
But we know by looking at it that this
difference makes a real difference.
A final study,
um,
and this was done by my colleague who
just got hired here, Jack to video,
who's done some wonderful work,
looked at how people judge to hire
somebody based on their recommendations.
Um,
this is a little bit of a confusing thing.
The green bars are to African Americans.
The blue bars are to white Americans and
in some cases these people have strong
recommendations when they have
strong recommendations. In 1989,
you're willing to hire everybody. And,
uh, this is not a difference at all,
but one of the recommendations are so,
so when it's a judgment call,
the subjects are significantly more
likely to hire the white American.
Then the African American 1989 was a
long time ago for the same results showed
up in 1999 the same results also
showed up about a year and a half ago.
And again, this doesn't show that
people are explicit, terrible racist.
It does show that people possess these
stereotypes that make a difference in
their real world behavior.
A way to put this all together is in a
interest divine's automaticity theory
theory,
which goes something like this.
The idea is that everybody
holds stereotypes.
These are automatically activated when
we come into contact with individuals.
In order to not act in
a stereotyped fashion,
we have to consciously push them down.
We have to consciously override
them and that's possible,
but it takes work.
It takes work both at the individual level
and it takes work at the group level.
Any questions or thoughts about this?
Yes.
Yup.
It's a good question.
It's a good question. These results,
these results are surprising, um,
and disturbing.
And I said there's,
there's work to be done in
individual and group level and,
and this young man challenged me to be
more explicit about that. Here's one case.
We have job searches
and and sometime jobs,
senior job searches involve the faculty
sitting around in a room and tossing out
names and we use these names as a
basis for further discussion. Hey,
I wonder what about that person?
That person does great work.
What we do now in a psychology department
is we make a special point of trying
to get names from disadvantaged groups,
not with an eye towards an
affirmative action policy,
but rather because there's
a lot of evidence suggesting
that people who are just
as qualified don't come to mind unless
you make some sort of procedure to do it.
Here's another example.
A lot of journals do blind reviewing now
because of the evidence I talked about
before regarding sexual stereotypes that
whether it has a male name or a female
name makes a difference.
So those are not,
those are group level and that they're
not saying you get rid of your prejudices
by trying harder.
It's rather let's set up a system
so that your prejudices can't work.
The blind auditions,
for instance,
being a beautiful example of
that at an individual level.
Your questions a harder one.
And I'm not exactly sure what we could do,
but I think what we should
do is be conscious of these
things and know that it's
not enough to say, well,
I'm explicitly not racist,
so I'll give everybody a fair shake.
But to recognize we might have biases
and to work hard to overcome them,
not by overcorrecting in some, in
some random way, but trying to,
if you're interested, for
instance, in qualifications,
setting up some system that these
qualifications can be observed absent
knowledge of race or sex. Yeah. And back.
Yeah.
Yes.
The question is a good one.
How much of this is due to stereotypes
and how much of this is due to an own
group bias? Um, so the fact that, so,
so the experiments as I've described
them are to some extent ambiguous.
The fact that white Americans favor white
Americans over black Americans might
be because of, um, of stereotypes,
but they also might be of
ingroup favoritism. Uh,
I think the answer is
that both play a role,
but some of the effects
are due to stereotypes, um,
above and beyond in group favoritism.
And one reason why we know that is in,
in studies like the IAT,
the implicit attitudes test
African-american show much
the same effect as white
Americans.
So African Americans also are biased
against African Americans and in favor of
white Americans showing it doesn't
reduce the group favoritism though that
probably plays a big role.
Okay.
Um,
I'm going to shift and spend the rest
of this class on a couple of mysteries.
Here's the summary.
Um,
the first one is a minor mystery.
I think we have some
progress and explaining it.
The second one is a total
mystery. The first one, sleep.
Um, sleep is a motivation. It is,
it is a motivation like food or drink.
Um,
if it is a form of torture, I won't get
into definitions of what torture is,
but it would cause somebody tremendous
pain and anguish to keep them from
sleeping. Uh, when you're really
tired, sleep is what you want to do.
Like when you're really hungry,
you wanna eat.
How many people here on average from the
beginning of the semester till now get
on average more than eight hours
of sleep a night? It's good. Good.
There's this sort of school of sleep.
There's a school of sleep macho.
I sleep macho used to be, I only get,
you know, 42 minutes of sleep a night.
Now Sleeve Mantras,
I sleep 11 hours.
Who gets on average more than seven
on average?
More than six.
Who here has been making it since the
beginning of semester on under six hours
in a night.
Okay.
Anybody viewed them as getting an
under five hours a night? Okay.
There's big individual differences in
how much sleep people need and sleep
itself is what we spend
a lot of our life on.
But it's very hard to study and we
didn't use to know much of it because you
can't ask people what's happening during
it cause they're sleeping. So you need,
you need sort of clever methods.
One such clever method is an EEG.
You bring somebody in a sleep lab,
you put electrodes on her
scalp and you see what these,
what sort of electoral activities
you get in the brain right now,
many of you are showing irregular Beta
waves suggesting intense comprehension
and great intellectual focus.
Some of you are awake but non attentive
and your brain's giving these large
regular alpha waves. Some of you
are sound asleep, deepened delta.
When you sleep, you get
the following stages. Uh,
you start off of a transition period.
When you're falling asleep,
we call that stage one. Then you get
successively deeper, two through four,
slow in regular,
high amplitude Delta waves.
And then once you reach stage four,
you start going up again up
through stage three and two.
Then rem sleep emerge as
rapid eye movement. Sleep.
Rem Sleep is neat cause your
brain looks like it's wide awake.
But, and I'm going to go talk a little
bit more in detail about this later.
You're relaxed, you're rapid eye
movements occur. That's where your,
the name comes from and dreams occur.
And then on a good night's sleep you've
got four to five sleep cycles and it
looks like this.
You start off,
you go down, down, down,
and now you come up.
Then you do your first
rem cycle again again,
again, again, and then you wake up.
So the general takeaway message here
is that there's two types of sleep.
There was slow wave sleep or quiet sleep.
Your eyes drift separately and slowly.
Your um,
your hard to wake up
vendor is rem sleep.
Your brain is active as if you were awake.
You're egs are similar to waking
paralyzed except for the eyes.
Oh men get erections
and you have dreams.
One sleep researcher joke that
these two are connected because um,
what happens is dreams fly around
through the ether and then the erection
service antennas.
So you picked up,
don't,
don't write that down.
Why do we sleep and why don't we,
why aren't we always wake there?
There's a couple of answers to this.
Um,
probably the best answer is um,
our body's worn out during the day and
sleep is necessary to put it back into
shape.
So when you sleep growth producing
hormone goes through the body,
your brain and other organs get restored.
Uh,
there are, um, you need less food.
Your immune system seems to
be hard at work. And in fact,
one answer. So people always wonder
what happens if you'd stopped sleeping?
And the answer is not a,
is not one discovered in the laboratory,
but it's been reported in different
cases. If you stopped sleeping, you die,
you don't die in some dramatic way,
you get sick and then you die.
Suggesting that sleeping is
good to keep you healthy. And a,
and an analogy I like to think
about is, um, is that you're,
when you bring your car into repair it
for repairs, when you repairing your car,
the first thing you do is you
stop it and shut off the engine.
You make it stable and at rest
so you can work on repair. Um,
a related view is that sleep,
uh,
emerged to preserve energy and
keep you at a trouble at night.
And these views are of
course not incompatible. Um,
this explains why we sleep at all and
this probably explains why we sleep at
night.
There are sleep disorders.
Um, I won't go through them. I
just list a few of them here.
Those sorts of bad things that could
happen to you when you're asleep. Um,
one particularly trendy sleep disorder
that's been discovered recently are side
effects of sleeping pills
such as ambien. So, um,
one of the bizarre side effects
is peep some people of Ambien, um,
while sleeping go downstairs,
open up their refrigeration,
eat huge amounts of food,
um,
are more recent side effect of Ambien.
That's quite serious
as some people become,
had the compulsion Waller
sleeping to go driving,
which is not not good.
What we're really interested in though,
when it comes to sleep, his dreams,
so remember Hamlet,
um,
people you all studied to hamlet to
be or not to be. That's all I know.
But basically he was deciding.
He, I wrote this down though,
he was deciding whether
or not to kill himself.
And so he made up two lists,
the list of reasons to kill himself.
We're the slings and arrows
of outrageous fortune,
a sea of troubles and the heartache and
the thousand natural shocks that flesh
is heir to.
He only had one argument not
to kill himself, nightmares
to sleep per chance to dream
for it in that sleep of death.
What dreams may come when we have shuffled
off this mortal coil might give us
pause. Um, he was
worried about nightmares.
Now dreams have always fascinated
people and philosophers.
If you take a philosophy course,
there'll be a couple of questions about
dreams that you were wondering about. Um,
one is,
are you dreaming right now?
So Rene Descartes famously wondered
whether the real world doesn't exist.
Maybe right now it's just a dream.
See also to matrix and can
you be a moral in a dream?
We do all sorts of things in dreams that
are bad are these since and the great
and the great theologians and philosophers
like Augustan wondered about this.
Can you sit in a dream?
I will answer both questions.
You are not dreaming right now
unless you're asleep. But if you're,
if you're normal and you can't
usually be immoral in a dream,
the exceptions are lucid dreams
where you choose what to dream about.
And then possibly you could be a moral
if you encourage bad habits of thought.
What do we know about dreams?
Well, first as a distinction,
a distinction between real
dreams versus sleep thought.
So real dreams are,
you know,
you're in a submarine wrestling
a chicken while your grandmother,
it looks disapprovingly on.
Those are real dreams. Um,
sleep thought is the sort of thing you
get typically before you fall asleep.
And it's like, did I take the garbage
out? Go ahead, take the garbage out.
Where's the garbage? Good
data garbage. They date the
garbage. And so sort of this,
this kind of rumination, and you
could do this while you're sleeping.
So if you're woken up during slow wave
sleep when we think and he'd take the
garden. Yeah, that's what I was dreaming.
I was thinking about the garbage.
But if you're woken up
during rem but a monkey,
it was eating my grandmother and that sort
of thing. So, so there's a distinction.
What do people dream about while we know
some facts but dream everybody dreams.
Not Everybody remembers their dreams.
If you want to remember your dream,
by the way, keep your dreams.
Keep a dream diary. Very useful.
But everybody dreams
three to four times a night.
That depends on how much sleep you get.
But Dreams, leaf, fragile memories,
they fade quickly.
This is why a dream diary or writing up
writing your dreams as soon as you wake
up, it turns out to be useful.
What do people dream about? Well,
basically the way to find that out is
you ask people and people have site
psychologists and sociologists have,
have collected dream reports.
Um, if you go to a Dream bank.net, um,
guy named hill collected
50,000 dream reports.
You can make some generalizations.
Most dreams are bad.
They're not bad, bad. They're not
nightmares. But most dreams are,
you know,
from a scale of one to 10,
with five and a half in the
middle there on the negative side,
they report misfortunes.
MMM.
People in tribal societies have dreams
with more physical aggression than people
in industrialized societies. Men have
more aggressive dreams than women.
Americans have more aggressive
dreams and Europeans. Yeah. Um,
what do people want to dream about?
While psychologist did this,
the findings were totally not going to
surprise you. Um, women want to greenbelt,
romance, and adventure. Men want
to dream about sex with strangers.
Turns out that once you get past the
hormonal blast of adolescence, um,
though 10% of dreams have
explicit sexual content,
what's the most common
dream guesses? Falling.
That's a good guess. Falling is among
the top names, but falling is not,
is not the winner.
Somebody else flying.
Also close public speaking,
good phobic dream but not it
naked in public Nigga budget.
Not at awesome.
Excellent being chased.
Evolutionary psychologists and cognitive
neuroscientists have puzzled over this
one.
It seems to be a sort of a primal dream,
but the dream about
being chased is a biggie.
Has Anybody here ever dreamt of being
chased that you could remember? Yeah.
You chase the big one,
make it and public
grandmother killed by monkey.
So
what are your dreams for
either our 40 and theories
that dreams are disguised?
Wish fulfillment and other things?
Um,
there's not much support for these.
One theory,
which is popular,
is that dreams are a side effect of
memory consolidation. So your body,
your body sort of below the neck
rebuilds itself while you're sleeping.
But also what happens while
you're sleeping is your
memories get played over and
over again. To consolidate them
in a different parts of the brain.
Almost the best analogy here
is backing up a computer.
Your brain backs itself up in
the course of backing itself up.
They're sort of random events,
flash to consciousness and get
put together in a coherent story.
From this perspective.
Dreams serve no adaptive function at all,
but rather their epi phenomenon are
the byproducts of another system.
Final topic is laughter
and this is a true mystery.
I am,
I got interested in as well.
I got interested as a
developmental psychologist
watching my own children laugh
and, and it's trying to figure out
what it is that made them laugh.
This is my son Zachary,
pretty young.
Um, for, this is not the youngest
record of, of laughing. Um,
I found this on the web.
Yeah,
it's, it's, it's,
it's a huge puzzle from an
evolutionary point of view.
People's pursuit of sex and food and
drink and sleep are not these huge
mysteries are abilities to understand
language and make sense of the visual
world and coherent groups. But,
but the fact that we make this,
this weird noise at bizarre
circumstances is a huge puzzle.
Um, and typical typically, um,
psychologists have failed to explain
this puzzle. So here's something I'm,
here's the first guess I read
in a neuroscience textbook.
We laugh when there is
incongruities between what we
expect and what we actually,
what actually happens unless
the outcome is frightening.
Now this is a fair effort.
It is about as wrong as anything
can be wrong in any possible way.
Um, first thing is it
doesn't really explain why.
So why should be a non frightening
incongruity caused people to make a
distinctive loud noise consisted of
Staccato stigmas of one 15th of a second,
each separated by a fifth of a second.
It doesn't explain why we make that loud
noise when dealing with incongruities.
It's not the case. That incongruity,
um, causes laughter. If there was,
um, if there was a bowl of
fruit up there as you walked in,
it'd be incongruous,
but people wouldn't shriek with
laughter and pointed a fruit. Um,
it's also
a lot of laughter isn't
caused by incongruity.
So a lot of times we laughed.
There's nothing in congruous
in any deep sense about it.
So laughter is kind of a puzzle. We
don't know why we laugh. We don't know.
Um,
what makes us laugh over the last five,
10 years,
there's been some work done on us.
A lot of the work is done by
Robert provene who summarizes
this in his excellent
book,
laughter and probing decided
to do something that nobody
in the history of the
world has done.
He decided to send himself in
his students to different places,
including shopping malls and
observe when people laughed
and write down what made them laugh.
And this is a first descriptive step
to developing a theory of laughter.
And his big finding is
that you could separate
people.
You could separate the
question of laughter from
the question of a joke or the
question of humor.
Most of what people would make people
laugh wasn't in any sense a joke or
humorous. So he had over a
thousand laughter initiated,
uh, situations. And here's him.
Typical comments that initiated
laughter sometimes are Rorty,
is laughter under parts of people.
I'll see you guys later.
Look, it's Andre. Are you sure? I know.
How are you? I try to lead a
normal life. It's sort of funny.
Does anyone in a context where it
wasn't particularly I'm using, um,
it wasn't you.
We can handle this.
Only 10% of the comments were it could be,
were coded later on as people as
actually humorous in any sense.
And these included, um, poor
boy looks just like his father.
You smell like you've had a good workout.
Did you find that in your nose?
Referenced the dormitory food.
Um,
he has a job holding back
skin and operating room. So,
so probing suggest we separate
the question of laughter, of,
of laughter and jokes,
and then ask what do we
know about laughter? Well,
here's some basic facts that,
that, remember, we're trying to think
like evolutionary biologists here.
Humans had this universal trait.
There's no society without laughter.
It's early emerging as we saw in
those clips. So what's it for?
What does it do is if it's an accident
and what's an accident from, well,
what properties does it have?
And there's some obvious properties
that are important to know.
It's social and communicative. Why
do we know that? Because it's loud.
Laughter is not, is not like
hunger. Hunger can be silent.
Hunger is not essentially a message
to other people. But when humans,
when it involves a loud noise,
the reason why we've evolved loud noises
is to communicate with other people.
Laughter could be viewed as a form
of involuntary, a noise making
and it's contagious. That's another
interesting thing about it. Um,
one of the great discoveries
in television and movies was,
um,
was the invention of the laugh track.
The laugh track makes things a lot funnier
because people laugh a lot more when
they were in groups.
Uh,
the rim shot after a comic remark is
an attempt to simulate as sort of a pre
technological attempt to
simulate the sound of laughter.
Children are particularly
influenced by the,
the contagiousness of laughter.
But just in general,
if you hear somebody laughing like,
like the kids you saw before is a sort of
thing that could easily make you laugh.
Other primates do it to some extent.
And it's interesting when they do it.
Um,
monkeys laugh when they
shit when they attack. Uh,
when monkeys get together
to kill an eat somebody,
they make a kind of a laughing noise
and chimpanzees laugh when they tickle
each other and we could see and what's
tickling?
Well,
a fair definition of tickling is touching
parts of the body in a mock attack.
Um, you sort of attack somebody and
they're laughing, but, but if it's,
but as far as trying to Mug you, you're
not, ah, that was so funny. You have to,
you have to realize that this is a
mock attack. You're simulating attack.
So one theory is, is a signal of mock
aggression and collective aggression.
It's basically a,
it's like a sound of some
sort of mob attack. Um,
it's mock aggression in a
sense that when people laugh,
they're often teasing kidding
around. Um, they're, they're,
they're, they're throwing out insults.
Maybe they're tickling each other.
Maybe they're making fun of each other.
Me and making fun of themselves.
And there's some aggression to it.
Most laughter is inspired by
some degree of aggression,
but it's attenuated and it's not real.
And the laughter is a signal.
This isn't a real and
collective aggression. Um,
a lot of mob assaults,
executions, lynchings,
rapes are accompanied to sound of
laughter when you were in a group doing
something terribly
aggressive and you are not,
you don't feel like you're at risk,
you might laugh and laughter's is a
signal to other members of the group as a
signal of solidarity and what
you're doing together. Um,
a different way of putting it.
And none of this is going to come in with,
with a sharp, decisive theory. These are
sort of flailing away at different ideas.
But another way of doing an older way is,
is bill brose by Plato.
Who of you. Laughter as a form of
bonding against the common enemy.
It's a sound. It's a sound of group
cohesion against the common enemy.
Um, comedians have not missed the
aggressive nature of laughter. Uh,
Dave Berry, right? The
most important humor,
truth of all is that to really
see the humor in a situation,
you have to have perspective. Perspective
is right from two ancient Greek words,
perse, meaning something bad
had happened to someone else.
And active meaning ideally
somebody like Donald Trump.
And the idea is that it's
something bad happening,
but not to you or to somebody you love.
Um,
Mel Brooks puts it in
so much sharper terms,
distinguishing between comedy and tragedy.
Tragedy is when I cut my finger.
Comedy's when you fall
an open sewer in guy
to sum up ingredients,
if humor is there has to be a
target who experiences some harm.
It can be an enemy. It could be
a friend, it could be yourself.
The harm shouldn't be as so serious
that it elicits strong negative emotions
like fear, grief, or
pity. So if a stranger,
you know, slips on a banana,
peel and lands on his butt,
I might laugh cause I'm not
overcome by compassion. You know,
if he split his head open,
there's blood everywhere,
I'm less likely to laugh unless
I don't like him or something.
And this is why the humor,
why damage is often a
certain sort of damage. Um,
involving things like embarrassment, sex,
autology, a banana peel pie in the face,
your pants fall down or something where
there was no real harm. So empathy,
caring, sympathy, don't
kick in. But instead,
here's the aggression
unleashed at somebody's. Um,
and it has to be some level of surprise.
This is what I'm,
this is where the humor
for that baby comes in,
which is why he couldn't predict when
the sound was coming and some aspect of
that was what made it so funny.
Then what elicited the laughter?
This is what elicit laughter for Zachary
was watching the classic film Winnie
the Pooh and a blustery day.
Um,
we're rabbit climbed in a high bunch of
shelves and it all came crashing down on
him, but he didn't, wasn't dead.
He was just kind of stunning.
Final question for anybody interested
in laughter is why can't we tickle
ourselves?
Now?
I've talked about laughter on two separate
occasions and Anesia they occasions
when I talked in front of
a large group like this,
somebody came up to me
afterwards and said, but I can,
and
I don't,
and they seem sincere, but people saying,
you know, I could do it all myself.
How many hate people here will own up
to being able to take on themselves?
It's a fascinating question
why some people can,
the general story of why we can't in
general is cause there's no surprise.
Um, there's no mark aggression and also
to maybe a general deadening of self
stimulation.
Um,
I'm going to end with the
final reading response.
Um,
think up an interesting testable
idea about either dreams or laughter.
You could go into as much
detail as you want if you want.
Your thing can be one sentence long,
but, but it could be longer. Um,
I will ask the teaching fellows does
each send me their one or two most
interesting remarks.
I will then judge and then the
winner will win some small price,
either of a literary or a food nature.
Okay,
I'll see you all on Wednesday.